well if I had a dollar for every time I
had to fight off a group of Assassins
while naked I'd be the richest man on
trantor Apple's Foundation season 2 has
been an incredible ride solidifying
apple as the go-to platform for sci-fi
and in this video we're going to take a
deep dive into season two and hopefully
answer some of the season's biggest
questions this will be a non-book
spoiler review but will still be going
over some theories on what could happen
in season 3 whereas season 1 focused on
the creation of foundation season 2
takes place over a hundred years later
and revolves around something known as
the second crisis an event that will
hail the dark times a thirty thousand
year period filled with war famine and
death it was Harry Selden who warned the
Empire that only by following his plan
can they shorten this period to A
Thousand Years something Cleon in the
genetic Dynasty has no intention of
following when we begin season 2 Gail
dornick shows her daughter salver
hardened the prime radiant device which
contains all the predictions concerning
the Empire expressed as a mathematical
equation according to Gale's
interpretation of the data the universe
is on the cusp of this second crisis an
event which will determine whether
Humanity continues on Harry's path or
one that sees catastrophic event after
catastrophic event for tens of thousands
of years this is the main conflict of
the season and sees Gail salvor and a
cloned Harry travel to the sparsely
populated planet of ignis Gail has the
ability to project her Consciousness
into the Future something she does in
episode 2. she believes this turning
point where the future has turned to
Darkness is 150 years away thus she
projects herself there and is introduced
to the mule there's not much we know
about him other than the fact that he's
an extremely powerful telepath who has
conquered much of the Galaxy he
according to Gail is the source of this
upcoming Darkness the mules in search of
the second foundation and its Army of
mentalics soldiers who have the ability
to read and shape the minds of others
this prompts Gail and the team to head
to ignis the location of the supposed
second Foundation Harry always had the
plan of two separate foundations that
would keep each other in check because
power corrupts and a foundation left
unchecked becomes Empire all over again
this is where we start the final episode
the leader of this ragtag group of
metallic survivors are led by a telepath
named telum who's used her powers to
call similar telepaths to live with her
in the Empire telepaths are treated with
condemnation we see what happened to
little Josiah and the people of his town
when they found out he was a telepath
anyone who can read your mind is a
threat but tell him is hiding a terrible
secret she basically has everyone in
this Refuge under her control and her
powers are so great that she can hijack
other people's bodies and essentially
live forever whenever her body gets old
she takes over the body of a child and
repeats the process a according to her
she's on her seventh Incarnation Now
tellum does not want to be part of this
second Foundation her main priority is
keeping her people safe and continuing
her own ruse so she tricks Galen salvor
into thinking Harry has left the planet
and abandoned them in reality she sent
the real Harry to his death to be
drowned by the tides and at the end of
episode 9 it's revealed that Harry has
miraculously survived as he saves the
day by killing tellum but how was this
possible according to Gail it was her
telepathy that allowed her to hear Harry
calling out to her their minds are
linked and she could feel what he felt
so when he was drowning it was like she
was drowning too she takes over Harry's
body and uses her power to force the
guard to unlock him thus allowing for
his escape and to finish it all off Gail
uses some mind trickery to change how
people perceive this now dead guard in
the water making him to look as though
it's Harry's dead body this is why when
salver finds him dead she sees Harry and
not the dead guard across the Galaxy on
the Empire Homeworld of trantor Rue and
dusk have found themselves imprisoned in
the secret lair of demersel in episode 9
my personal favorite of the Season we
hear the tragic story of how demersell
came to be as a boy before the genetic
dynasty was even a thing young Cleon the
first discovered a hidden room in the
palace that hadn't been touched in
thousands of years there he found an
imprisoned demarzel her body segmented
in several parts according to her she is
over 18 000 years old having spent five
thousand of those years imprisoned here
she wasn't always called demersell
implies this wasn't always her body as a
leader in the robot wars a war which
Humanity won it was Emperor aberanus who
had her imprisoned and studied rather
than kill her he had her body segmented
but were never really given a reason as
to why she wasn't killed especially
considering demrazel says she's the key
to making more of a robotic kind
something that could prove very Danger
risk to humanity over the years Cleon
grew to love dimmerzel and turned down
all other proposals of marriage none of
the women in his life could compare to
her thus he came up with a plan the
genetic Dynasty with demersel charged
with preserving the Dynasty and de facto
running the Imperium but the most
important detail is the brief moment
Cleon sets demerzel free before he
inserts this chip in this moment she
could easily snap his neck and walk to
freedom but she doesn't could it be
because she truly loves him well Cleon
takes this moment to insert a chip into
her one which Alters her programming
under this new set of rules she cannot
bring harm to him nor can she transmit
her programming into another entity now
you might ask yourself how was demarzel
able to kill brother dusk if she can't
bring harm to him I've come up with
three wildly different theories on this
the first is that brother dusk was never
killed we never see her actually kill
him so it's possible he's still out
there somehow the second is that her
programming has been changed remember
it's been 600 years since Cleon put that
chip in her in episode 7 we also hear
that dimmersell is only Bound by one law
now I'm Bound by only one law which is I
serve Empire if her primary directive is
to serve Empire she can theoretically
kill dusk if it means serving the Empire
and finally Theory 3 is that cleon's DNA
has been manipulated to such an extent
that his clones are no longer exact
copies allowing demarzel to kill them
remember in season 1 that one of the
brother Dons was born left-handed and
with different color eyes than their
original clion something he tried to
keep hidden it was later found that
someone had been manipulating their
genetic code little by little if Den
Brazil's primary directive is to serve
Empire she would have to be against
brother day marrying sarath and ending
the genetic Dynasty part of the reason
day wants to end the Dynasty is to prove
that Harry Selden is wrong Selden had
said the genetic Dynasty weakened the
Empire so brother day Destiny into his
own hands and ends it himself but little
does he know that demarzel won't allow
this to happen she was the one who
coordinated the failed assassination
against him in episode 1 in an attempt
to frame sarath and end the engagement
by the end of the season dimmersell has
decanted three new cleons essentially
able to start from scratch and continue
the genetic Dynasty meanwhile brother
day basts in the glory of having
completely annihilated Terminus the
foundation and its people he then orders
General Bell Rios to attack and destroy
the seven other planets who had joined
the foundation something the general
disobeys as it would be killing millions
of innocent civilians and what he calls
a quote the moral ruin of Empire Cleon
then orders she Ben's light a spacer to
take over and launch the jump to the
next planet but unbeknownst to Cleon
this has started a chain reaction
whereby a folded spaceship jumps into
the next one creating a chain reaction
of ships jumping into each other this
specific jump sequence was hidden in the
body of hober Malo when under orders
from Harry Selden made an alliance with
the spacers the spacers are genetically
modified beings who operate Imperial
jump ships and due to their
modifications need a micronutrient
called opolisk in exchange for this
nutrient the Empire demands that 10 of
their people be relegated to operate
Imperial jump ships since only spacers
can do this work but what Cleon doesn't
know is the foundation has a the ability
to fold space without the use of spacers
and B created a synthetic Obelisk so
that spacers will no longer have to rely
on the Empire thus the spacers agree to
sacrifice some of their people in this
Ploy for their overall Freedom
understandably the quick to anger Cleon
takes out his frustration on hober and
Bell Rios Belle has assorted history
with Cleon not taking his orders being
sent to a slave labor camp told his
husband's been murdered only to find out
he's alive and that he'll have to kill
him by blowing up Terminus they have a
great fight with bell being tossed out
of the airlock but in a brilliant twist
during the fight Bell slipped on a
casterling device the same device Hobart
mallow used in episode 3 in his attempt
to steal the eye of Corel it allows the
users who wear to switch places so as
Belle is thrust out of the airlock he
clicks the device and swap places with
Cleon who freezes to death with the
destruction of terminus in the backdrop
and just a reminder if you like these
types of videos please leave a like And
subscribe every little bit helps the
channel out back on trantor Dawn demands
to know why his secret lover the
would-be empress sarath has been
arrested Dawn can't do much seeing as
demarzel knows he was secretly having an
affair with the woman who is set to be
wed today but dusk has left a warning
for Dawn on Denver Zell herself a smudge
of green paint in episode 5 dust told
Dawn about how green is the color of a
betrayer so this little Mark indicates
she's not to be trusted this is what
prompts him to storm into Sarah's room
and rescue her the last we see of them
the two are on a ship leaving trantor
with sarath proclaiming that she is
pregnant with Dawn's child this could
mean this unborn child has a claim to
the throne constant is the only one to
survive the explosion of the Imperial
ship having said a heartfelt goodbye to
hober who dies in the blast she managed
to escape in an external cleaning module
where she'll eventually be picked up by
Harry Selden and the Vault it seems to
have made its way off Planet before the
blast and as we'll soon see it took
everyone from foundation with it
remember that the Vault doesn't operate
within the confines of physics as we
know it so while it may look like this
on the outside on the inside it can
house thousands of people I also found
it interesting that they let Glau and
kerr come with them he was Belle's
husband and an imperial fighter
basically an enemy so I'm curious if
there will be plans for him in the
future I also want to bring attention to
the fact that time works differently in
the vault it's only been about one or
two hours since Terminus was destroyed
and constant was picked up yet for the
people in the vault it may seem seem
like days so I'm curious if this will
come into play next season back on
ingness Gail salvar and Harry have
joined forces with tellum's crew after
it was revealed they were under tell him
spell but tell him although dead has
jumped into the mind to poor Josiah over
here who is mind controlled to kill Gail
luckily salvor steps in the way and
takes the shot killing Josiah and salvor
in the process this has great
implications because this isn't where
salvor was supposed to die according to
Gail's Vision sour was supposed to die
150 plus years into the future at the
hands of the mule this suggests that
changing the future is possible you were
right the future can be changed if this
can be changed can they also change the
impending Darkness to come but this is
not to say salvor still won't die in the
future in a show that has clones
cryosleep and the uploading of one's
Consciousness there are no doubt ways we
could see salvor once again looking at
the prime radiant Gail says the path is
still off course there still had headed
toward this great crisis in the future
she doesn't want salvor's death to be in
vain and thus Harry devises a plan for
the two of them to take on the mule and
change the future originally Harry
wanted kale to become this almost
god-like figure going into cryosleep to
emerge once a year to get updates on
what's Happening and provide inspiration
to this burgeoning second Foundation
meanwhile Harry would stay with the
second foundation and over time
eventually die Gail doesn't accept this
if she's to fight she needs Harry and
thus the two decide to cry or sleep
together it's never mentioned whether or
not the two will come out of cryo every
year such was Harry's original plan but
I imagine they would after dimrazel
decants three nucleons she shows them
her new tool a prime radiant given to
her by Harry Selden in episode 9. I
think Harry knows that dimmersell will
be pivotal in the upcoming battles to
save Humanity just look at the way he
turns to her while reciting this line
future is invented
every second
invent a better one Harry wanted Denver
Zell to have this Prime radiant and even
offered to teach her how to read the
math within it so when dim mirzell says
there are quote wonderful things ahead
it could mean many things with the help
of Harry she might be able to finally
break free of her programming in The
Flash Forward with the mule we know that
the Empire no longer exists 150 years in
the future so I expect next season we'll
see its downfall for good and that
demrazel is key to its ruin whether it
be consciously or subconsciously and the
final thing we need to discuss is the
last scene 152 years into the Future
featuring The Mule it looks like he
could be on the same planet we saw him
on in Gale's Flash Forward with sounds
of war in the background it's not clear
whether he's talking to someone or to
himself but I think we can make out his
electric hand Cannon thing in the
foreground he is on a mission to find
Gail and kill her before she kills him
one of the things I'm looking forward to
the most is why the mule is destroying
all these planets to get to Gale what is
his motivation also so who is the mule
is he a completely new character or
could he be a character we already know
inhabiting his body we saw how tellum
can take over different bodies and
demerzel hinted that she had been in a
different body before too I think the
most WTF thing the writers could do here
is make it so that the mule is actually
Gale or Harry Selden in the mule's body
after all this is a Sci-Fi show there
are ways it can be done but I could just
see that being a truly shocking moment
if it's written well with compelling
motivation I thoroughly enjoyed this
season and rumors have it that the third
season has started production but an
official announcement has yet to be made
now I want to know what you thought of
season two leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
pinkstory yd until next time remember
you're a spoon led by its waving
pledging mistakingly Trend emotion for
complexity